yes we are with
former champ sam shanklin sam a good win
for you it seems though that you're not
feeling so thrilled
about your performance i mean would you
be thrilled with my performance come on
i'd be happy with that score actually if
i were in your shoes but i know you're a
different caliber player yeah it's
certainly been a very rough tournament
just like the exhaustion was not easy
i've not been feeling great and honestly
i haven't been sleeping that well in
some of these rounds but you know i'm
glad that even one
feels like the world is collapsing on me
i can still play a reasonable game and
keep my head on straight and fight till
the end because
you know
i was at least happy to win one game or
not two but it you know
yeah
apologies because we were following
other games uh in the mix
if we if i may switch out because
there's a performance that happened here
in carissa yip that reminded me of your
performance when you won your
championship you just started winning
everything and dominating uh what are
your thoughts about how this young lady
has done well more power to her i've
spoken with her now and i don't know i
think she has a lot of potential and a
great job i fully expect her to make it
to grandmaster and beyond in the coming
years if she keeps taking it as
seriously as she is now um i would
caution her against playing the
hippopotamus in important games
when she starts playing stronger events
than us women's but uh no it's certainly
great to see a promising young american
have success like that absolutely your
thoughts watching the open itself plus
two with everybody all bunched up in the
top like this it's incredibly
demoralizing of course and i when i won
this one had plus six and like so i just
felt like if i'd even remotely
reasonable form i'd have like very
serious chances to fight i'm like only a
point out of first despite playing like
horrible really horrible chess the whole
way through so
it's a little demoralizing but hey i
mean there i think there was a euro plus
three won the tournament as well so but
i guess look if all the top players are
tired and you know the the 2800s you're
playing like 2700s and 2750s you're
playing like 26.75 then you know the
guys who are starting at that rating
have every bit of a chance to fight if
they're in good form so i don't know i
haven't really been following very
closely i've just been trying to focus
on my own games but i guess it's set up
for an exciting finish
that's what i was going to ask you you
said you're not following very closely
who you think maybe comes out of this i
i don't no i if it's not going to be me
at this point so beyond that i don't
really care i mean i i i just played
badly and in a year where really if
anybody had played remotely well they
would have just run away with the
tournament but so far nobody everyone's
just playing bad so
you know that's how it goes plus two or
plus three will win this year but you
know stranger things have happened all
right well thanks so much for joining us
and good luck in your last oh wait a
minute you played fabian the last game
which may be a necessary win for him
your attitude going into that one it's
just another game just play it like any
other
i mean all right good luck sure thank
you for joining us sam and good luck
tomorrow in
the championship